[Musique]
trente minutes pour devenir professeur
c'est l'initiative lancée par l'académie
de versailles ce lundi matin l'opération
organisée en partenariat avec pôle
emploi vise à recruter du personnel
enseignant et on y trouve tous les
profils de candidats
j'ai eu quatre enfants ça m'a intéressé
de faire le programme de maths avait que
deux mille postes sont à pourvoir pour
la rentrée de septembre mais sur les
réseaux sociaux beaucoup dénoncé
formation express en qualifications
spécifiques
nous on doit passer des masters et
accepté d'aller bosser là où un poste
est libre et si on refuse on est bannie
de l'éducation nationale mais en trente
minutes tu peux être prof alors face à
la pénurie d'enseignants soutenez-vous
les formations exprès pour devenir
professeur
souvenez-vous les formations exprès pour
devenir professeur non non oui vous
c'est formidable et c'est formidable
bravo
pôle emploi fort tous ceux qui sifflent
ne connaissent rien à l'éducation rien
aux enfants
[Applaudissements]
voilà juste aussi ce qui est bleu de
chauffe et soeurs il n'ya plus
d'enseignants d'autres
donc il en faut dans les écoles il faut
recruter et ces gens que j'ai entendu
ils ont une vocation il aurait voulu
être prof c'est leur deuxième chance de
les re su j'aurais voulu être
footballeur connard
[Applaudissements]
à
jean servat absent et c'est le futur
découper un poulet ont bien chirurgie en
[Applaudissements]
en mai
tandis que national manque de
professeurs mais ne faisons pas des
professeurs au rabais les professeurs
qui j'ai entendu un monsieur qui est
certainement armée de la meilleure
attention du monde qui dit je fais les
mathématiques avec une 6 j'avais envie
de devenir prof de maths mais c'est pas
parce que tu fais les devoirs y compris
ce que tu vas être un bon premier roman
vous pallier les absences il est sous
les profs qui ne sont pas remplacés dans
les collèges d'île de france les
professeurs ne seront pas remplacés et
donc il faut des gens dont plan d'eau
ont donc on leur donne des professeurs
qui ne sont pas formés mais qu'est ce
que vous en
savez et nous ceux qui auront les mois
le client de tous ses enfants inscrits
du sio qui va venir hommage et surtout
manifestée moi j'y serai c'est pour
l'emploi qui manie qui qui est en train
de faire des formations magnifique et
vous voulez méprisés c'est parce que
vous êtes une jeune homme
jusqu'à mon cousin
car des gens il ya des gens qui vont
trouver des égouts d'adieu
on dira toujours que c'est
justement celle inverse du snobisme
parce que qu'est ce qui va se passer
mais se passe pas c'est que ceux qui ont
de l'argent vont enlever leur gêne
évidemment pour les mettre dans le privé
avec des professeurs qui sont formés
pour être professeur il y aura donc une
école à deux vitesses avec des enfants
qui seront obligés de rester avec des
professeurs qui n'auront pas été formés
les outils pédagogiques qui sont
adéquats pour leur nouveau et pour la
classe je suis désolé donc c'est le
palier cessé de boire il
[Applaudissements]
y avait des choses à quoi à votre moitié
des profits si oui là oui
c'est intéressant
ils sont d'accord avec gilles là ils
sont d'accord avec
notamment des peintures d'études le
cadre s etc la zone 30 minutes masi
autres hypokhâgne et où vous êtes une
jeune homme élevé
quelle classe
mais ça riait la
54e et et elle a des profs qui sont
absents qui ne sont pas remplacés près
de vivre vivre ces formations concert
quelqu'un qui a qui ajuste un niveau moi
demain matin ça veut dire que demain
matin je peux être professeur jamais
aucun outil pédagogique parce que tu que
tu as fait des études que tu as un bon
professeur ça n'a rien à voir là ils ont
non seulement les études avec deux ans
supplémentaires par rapport à ce qui est
demandé et en plus ils passent un examen
spécifique s'appelle le capes pour
savoir s'ils ont des outils je suis pas
idiot mais pas une leçon d'éducation
qu'après sans rien perdre tu brad exact
ça situe brad l'éducation et moi
adorions pallie les manques il y a des
absents eric castaldi réveille toi merci
ce
qui s'est dit
vous avez changé de ton
maintenant j'ai une vraie raison c'est
vrai
moi qui décide non mes blagues et
pendant la fête alors j'y vais un peu
trop lents comme d'habitude mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya un vrai problème est que
effectivement parce qu'on fait cinq ans
d'études il se peut qu'on est un bon
professeur ils m ont fait peu ou moins
d'études qu'on ait un mauvais
professeurs donc on peut c'est vrai
c'est vrai je suis désolé j'ai eu des
profs qui avait fait quitter par les
dégoûter nul et diakité par bah oui mais
non mais dis donc ici et où depuis quand
depuis quand tu fais plein d'études donc
si tu étais un bon prof
donc là c'est une formation il l'a dit
mais un plan de soutien de 30 noms de
l'entretenir cémoi située hors
effectivement
c'est pendant ces patrons péter pas vrai
si c'est non mais plus tard mais je vais
vous dire moi pourquoi parce que mon
compagnon mon compagnon péter
of wwii non il est pas prof justement et
au collège
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est tony c'est
maintenant il attaque il a quoi pas tant
celle à quoi les laguna - déjà la
chorale pôle emploi l'a appelée qui tue
paul oui pôle emploi l'a appelé pour lui
demander s'il souhaitait bon l'emploi
justement un rendez vous pour être
professeur n'y en a aucune formation il
est et on lui proposait d'être
professeur d'histoire il a il est
cultivé il a fait des études etc mais là
aucune formation il a décliné mais et
donc on lui proposait du jour au
lendemain quand il n'ya pas de devenir
professeur en à moi pardon on avait des
petits quant à la raison et on n'entend
pas brader on brade l'alhambra de
l'éducation au bras de la santé en force
à la promesse et le tableau ils ont dit
1700 euros un an ou à l'est où il est le
blanc elle pète prof c'est un plan de
carrière non mais vous rigolez mais
c'est une vocation c'est un plan de
carrière tu fais pas prof un an et après
tu bats à rungis conduire des camions
1700 brut en mêlée on parle de nos
enfants on parle de l'avenir de la
france et on n'arrive pas à trouver de
la thune pour former et prog menthe et
des profs et dvd avec servier
[Applaudissements]
en amérique regardez qu'est ce qu'ils
font en amérique arrêtés
tirés de séries dont on parle mais là
ils ont fait passer des balles
caoutchoutées civile avait fait tout à
leurs besoins
on parle de nos enfants on part de 1700
broussailleux renouvelables n'attendez
pas des intrus
éducation nationale on reprendrait dès
qu'on met enseignement national c'est
pas parce qu'elle avait des corps
partout
moi je serais vraiment à bout je veux
faire passer une loi enseignement
national j'étais au restaurant il ya
quelques temps grâce à l'otan brassera
cyril avait des missiles c'est moi qui
nomme et cyril abou jaoudé serré que sa
palce iris cambray
jeudi aura qu'un seul cyril
non mais ça non mais ça parce que
j'avais syrie à la radio
c'était qui salon une femme
alors autant quelques mois
revenons sur l'éducation comme
d'habitude gilles tu es complètement à
côté de la plaque était aveuglé par la
démagogie est évidemment valérie a
absolument tout dit c'est à dire que
plus on va finalement baisser la qualité
à la base plus on va on va créer une
sorte de fossé sociaux ou les gens
partiront des écoles les gens donc les
plus avantagés les plus fortunés donc
c'est juste une catastrophe et je vais
citer le tweet du secrétaire national du
pc que vous aimez beaucoup fabien
roussel qui dit 30 minutes pour devenir
pilote d'avion non 30 minutes pour
devenir chirurgien non 38 pour devenir
policier non il est temps que l'école de
la république retrouve son attractivité
et ils interpellent et munis de
l'éducation nationale et c'est là que
raymond a raison parce que oui il faut
d'abord un une vraie formation et de des
bons salaires et ses salles à la base du
problème c'est les salaires sais c'est
pas possible que les profs soient aussi
peu payé aussi mal payés voilà je vous
me dites ainsi je vous fais chier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que ça s'est vu
au loin j'ai dit non c'est bon
dany géraldine a tout dit mais je vais
quand même essayer de prendre un exemple
pas le cas l'état tabac
et prendre un exemple compréhensible
pour pour gilles gard moi je cherche un
ami idéal depuis des années des années
c'est pas pour ça que je vais te prendre
toi vous ramène
[Applaudissements]
c'est
dur ce soir elle et tous n'ont ménagé
c'est la mode a refusé gila croyez pas
aimé ça fait plusieurs fois là je suis
d'accord avec guillaume sa suite est
d'accord que je sens je me rapproche ma
couille
[Applaudissements]
nous rejoignons ne la tient au coût de
la vie
dans cette émission aujourd'hui c'est
quand ça m'a
complètement l'avenue john
pas possible mais franchement on dirait
qu'elle à l'accueil de la country club
non mais en fait comme souvent le cas
votre problème à l'envers sakho ludovic
valorisé socialement et financièrement
le métier de professeur à la va chercher
des gens dont c'est pas du tout le
métier pour les payer moins cher des
gens qui sont prêts à travailler et
qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec ça c'est
n'importe quoi c'est un manque de
respect pour le métier de professeur qui
travaillait dur pendant des années c'est
un métier très utile et après on doit
former les jeunes plus de les instruire
et parfois les éduquer et là on leur
manque de respect alors dit quelque part
votre travail ça ne vaut rien que ces
périls et en plus ça mais crée une
grande précarité dans le métier de fou
mais carragher terry il faut absolument
que ça
les regards des gens pensent les
téléspectateurs car ils m'intéressent
beaucoup plus que vauban douala non à
83% voilà à ses deux enfants oui voilà
je vous dire c'est
ccir d'avancer très fort ce que vous
avez tous disent ils
il est peu écoutés mais j'essaie